[Музика]
привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської мови
мене звати Наталія начісування для вій,
давайте почнемо, тому сьогодні ми збираємося
розпочати нову тему, яка
буде наступною, тому я прошу вас
вгадати, подивіться ми  мати дуже
малу частину картинки спробуйте вгадати я
впевнений, що ви пам'ятаєте цю картинку
з наших попередніх уроків так, ви маєте
рацію, це м'ячі, і ми будемо
говорити про спорт, тож
почнемо, буде завдання  бо
ви подивіться на павукову землю, ми збираємося
створити її разом, обговорюючи
заняття спортом,
тож давайте подумаємо над прикметниками, а
я напишу це на дошці,
так що займатися спортом це добре, але
цікаво чи нудно, просто напишіть
ідеї  разом зі мною ми будемо
використовувати ці прикметники трохи пізніше сьогодні,
так що спортивні давайте з різними
прикметниками це добре так це добре деякі
з вас можуть сказати, що ні спорт поганий, добре, давайте
залишимо це тут, це цікаво, добре
, це здорово,
звичайно  як щодо веселощів  Іноді
це весело, але в якийсь момент це може бути небезпечно
, ви погоджуєтеся,
давайте з одним прикметником, гм, я
люблю захоплююче, тому займатися спортом цікаво,
ви можете написати свої прикметники, вони
можуть відрізнятися від моїх, або ви можете створити
комбінацію мої слова  і знову ваші слова,
ми будемо використовувати ці
прикметники пізніше під час нашого уроку, давайте
перейдемо далі, тому подивіться на слова, у нас
сьогодні багато слів, нічого страшного, якщо ви
не знаєте деяких слів, тож давайте
перевіримо, яке з них ви знаєте  і який з
них ви не знаєте, так що йога, я думаю, це
легко, це те саме на нашій мові,
що ще,
мабуть, килимок, це невеликий килим,
який ви використовуєте для занять, що ще
хокей, це знову щось
подібне, так що давайте з  слова
по одному, але перед цим давайте розділимо
їх на дві групи різні види спорту
та різне обладнання, яке нам потрібно для
занять спортом, тому давайте почнемо зі спорту,
подивимося та знайдемо п’ять різних видів
спорту,
давайте перевіримо, подивіться йога r  epeat
after me
yoga snow clean
you Повторяйте за мною підводне плавання з маскою,
гарний хокей і знову хокей, гарний
сноуборд і знову ідеальний сноуборд,
і кікбоксинг кікбоксинг,
тож подивіться на ці п'ять ваших
улюблених або, ймовірно, вам не подобаються
всі, наприклад, для  я б
пішов на снорклінг.
обговоримо їх
сьогодні, тож давайте почнемо поглянути на
цю спортивну йогу. Це тип вправи,
призначений для очищення розуму та підтримки ваших
ніг, як правило, для мене це виглядає так,
наприклад, тому це буде
скриня, яку я збираюся  щоб використовувати для йоги
згадайте, що це за йога, то що
нам потрібно для йоги, нам потрібен килимок,
подивіться жінка сидить на підлозі, але у
неї є килим, тому синій килим
називається килимком для йоги, ми зазвичай використовуємо
килимок, давайте  рухайся  тож ми вже
використовували килимок, давайте обговоримо підводне плавання, що
це таке, що це плавання під водою, використовуючи
трубку, щоб допомогти вам дихати, так що якщо
ви під водою і хочете дихати,
то вам потрібно використовувати трубку, добре, тож якщо
ви подивитеся на картинку, це жінка
використання трубки, тож цей жест
буде для підводного плавання, а що це за
йога та це снорклінг Браво, тож давайте
подивимося на спорядження, що нам потрібно
для підводного плавання.
Гоголь повторює за мною окуляри
це окуляри, які ви використовуєте, коли
пірнаєте у воду  або ми можемо використовувати окуляри,
коли ми катаємося на сноуборді, щоб вони захищали
нас від вітру чи снігу,
іноді навіть від піску, давайте рухатися,
що це за жовті речі, які ми
називаємо ластами, це гумові чоботи,
які ми використовуємо, коли ми пірнаємо або пірнаємо з
маскою  тож подивіться на жінку, вона
не одягнена в купальник, тому вона одягнена
в спеціальний костюм, який називається гідрокостюм,
хороший ще раз
для підводного плавання нам потрібні окуляри ласти
трубка і гідрокостюм нагадують  я, що
це добре, це йога та це
підводне плавання, добре зроблено, давайте йти далі, тому ми
вже використали ласти гідрокостюм,
окуляри для снорклинга та килимок, давайте йти далі,
давайте поговоримо про хокей, так що це
командний вид спорту, який грають на льоду, добре, що нам
потрібно для  хокей давайте обговоримо перш
за все нам потрібні ковзани це спеціальні
черевики для того, щоб кататися на ковзанах
що ще щоб захистити
себе завжди потрібно носити шолом, тому
ковзани і шолом для гравця і
для гри вам потрібні  шайба чорна річ,
яка використовується для хокею та ключка,
тому ще раз шайба та ключка
добре зроблені, тож давайте подумаємо про
жест для хокею це йога, це
не охолоджує лід, ми будемо таким
для
хокею  потрібен
рюкзак для ковзанів і шолом, давайте подивимося на
картинку, а що залишилося боксерські рукавички,
боксерська сумка для сноуборду та тренажери, тож
яким буде наступний вид спорту, чи можете ви
здогадатися, сноуборд,
давайте розглянемо заняття, під час якого люди
користуються сноубордом  записувати сніг we
heels це дуже популярно в Україні тому
сноуборд що нам для цього потрібно
сноуборд спеціальне спорядження для
сноуборду без сноуборду
не можна кататися на сноуборді так і
шолом для захисту голови так що згадайте
що це за хокей  і ця йога, і
цей снорклінг, а
як щодо сноуборду, хм, нехай це буде
так,
добре, це не відбувається насправді так,
як цей сноуборд, давайте перейдемо до
того, що є останнім боксерським поглядом, боксерська сумка і
тренажери, чи можемо ми вгадати спорт, так,
це кікбоксинг,
так що кікбоксинг  вид бойового мистецтва і
що нам потрібно для кікбоксингу в першу
чергу нам потрібні боксерські рукавички і боксерська
груша, це боксерська груша, тому
насправді те, що ти б'єш, і ти скажеш
мені Наталія, а тренери, так,
ми можемо мати, ми можемо  використовуйте тренажери для
кікбоксингу, і ми можемо використовувати їх для
бігу підтюпцем для футболу та багатьох багатьох
інших видів спорту, тому давайте використовувати для кікбоксингу
боксерську грушу та боксерські рукавички, а тренажери
залишимо їх так  нагадайте мені, що це
добре, добре, молодці, молодці, і
це буде кікбоксинг, добре зроблено, тому
тренери
залишили, тому що ми можемо використовувати їх у
різних видах спорту кікбоксинг,
футбол знову баскетбол, тож іноді
навіть йога, якщо ви займаєтесь цим не
вдома, а на вулиці  давайте йти далі, тож давайте
пограємо в гру, спочатку це буде гра у вгадування,
я буду тестувати вас востаннє,
так що цей один хокей
кікбоксинг молодець йога підводне плавання
сноуборд молодець подивіться на
фотографії так що йога хокей сноуборд
кікбоксинг  і підводне плавання з маскою, ми збираємося
грати в гру, якого не вистачає виду спорту, тому
подивіться на фотографії та швидко вгадайте,
якого тут немає один два три
так, хокей, добре, давайте спробуємо ще
раз подивіться на ці фотографії один два
три Браво підводне плавання і  останній раз
один два три так кікбоксинг добре зроблено
це було легко,
тому що лише п'ять видів спорту
давайте з обладнанням, тому у нас є багато
фотографій, давайте переглянемо, так що це за
палка а бу  nch назад ковзани ласти
килимок шолом для снорклінгу окуляри сноуборд тоді у
нас є боксерські рукавички гідрокостюм парк і
кросівки готові,
так що Ready Steady Go подивіться, чого зараз не
вистачає, і
я впевнений, що це парк, який був нелегким, тому що у нас так
багато фотографій тут
давайте спробуємо ще раз я дам вам п'ять
секунд, щоб перевірити фотографії п'ять чотири
три два один
скажіть, будь ласка, окуляри давайте повторимо
окуляри це не Google, це Google
чого не вистачає три два один
так шолом, тож перейдемо до ще одного
завдання  для вас просто швидко назвіть
спорядження. Я дам вам десять секунд,
і давайте перевіримо a Я зустрів, бути трубкою, подивитися,
що має D ласти електронний шолом f ковзани
G палка H a шайба I шолом J
сноуборд ka ударити назад L  боксерські рукавички
та тренажери M, молодці, давайте йти далі, у
нас є п'ять різних видів спорту,
що ми робимо, коли ми займаємося спортом, нам
потрібно використовувати різні дієслова do play або
go,
щоб грати хокей – це командний вид спорту,
і ми граємо в цю гру  тому ми говоримо грати в
хокей  але як щодо вас і піти,
мабуть, з наших попередніх уроків ви
пам'ятаєте, що ми займаємося йогою, чим ще
ми займаємося, ми займаємося кікбоксингом, а для го ми використовуємо
кататися на сноуборді або підводним плаванням, давайте
перевіримо, лизати, чи займатися йогою чи
кікбоксингом, грати в хокей, йти на снорклінг
а зараз катайся на сноуборді, давайте потренуймося в
різних реченнях із прислівниками
частоти, тому зазвичай і ти додаєш
діяльність я завжди, а ти кажеш
діяльність або я ніколи, наприклад, я
зазвичай займаюся йогою, тому це не завжди
зазвичай я завжди займаюся підводним плаванням, коли я
подорожую  море знову я завжди займаюся
підводним плаванням, коли їду на море,
що з тобою, що ти завжди робиш
і останнє речення я ніколи H мм я ніколи не
займаюся кікбоксингом я не люблю битися
це не мій вид спорту
я віддаю перевагу йозі, а ти  просто скажи
свої речення добре, давайте йти далі,
тому я хочу, щоб ви описали різні
види спорту та використовуйте прикметники
чи пам’ятаєте ви, що ми написали
прикметники на початку нашого
уроку, тож у нас є m  ore прикметники тут
давайте подивимося, коли нам щось подобається,
ми можемо сказати, що це весело, ми розважаємось добре,
захоплююче, у мене також є захоплююче, а що
щодо вас, у вас є це у вашому списку,
давайте рухатися далі, це справді це дуже
гарне слово, розслабляючи, добре  і дивно, якщо
вам щось не подобається, ви можете сказати, що
це нудно або це небезпечно і втомливо,
іноді напружує, а нудний нудний є
синонімом слова нудний, тож давайте скажіть
кілька речень мені подобається, хм, що мені подобається,
добре, мені подобається йога, тому що це  розслаблюю
або ви можете сказати, що я не люблю йогу, тому що
це нудно, давайте спробуємо більше речень.
Мені подобається кікбоксинг, тому що він пронизливий,
це приємно або я не люблю
кататися на сноуборді, тому що це небезпечно
.  перевірте Я хочу, щоб ви назвали слова,
які починаються з однієї літери, тож я
дам вам літери, а ви дайте
мені обладнання чи будь-які інші слова, які ми
використовуємо сьогодні,
давайте спробуємо, тож давайте почнемо з першої літери T
давайте почнемо з T тренажери  молодці
запишіть кросівки і оголошено,
що ми використовуємо сьогодні, давайте почнемо з Т хм
я не пам'ятаю добре
давайте наступна літера H шолом Браво добре
давайте продовжимо w водне поло
О, Наталя, ми сьогодні не використовували це, що
починається з W гідрокостюм  Браво добре, а як
щодо F
f хмм ласти гарні ласти Rajon
давайте з G це моє улюблене слово, яке
починається з G окуляри, добре зроблено, якщо ви
подивитеся на це слово,
це дуже цікаво, у ньому три літери G
це цікаво,
давайте йти далі.  це будь
яка та тонка шайба добре, і давайте
з s у нас є кілька слів, які
починаються на S сноуборд
добре зроблено або сноуборд що ще ви
пам'ятаєте цю річ шноркель добре зроблений
і пахне
гарно зроблено, тож давайте з  останньою
літерою на сьогодні буде B, хм,
я поставлю її тут
і спробую працювати так, що
з B нам потрібно це для цього виду спорту
так, боксерські рукавички і востаннє я
їм обіцяв пам'ятати, що мій улюблений вид спорту
- йога, то що робити  ми н  eed for yoga mat
well done so well done with all
words now давайте потренуємося в них з
реченнями, то що нам потрібно для
підводного плавання, нагадайте мені, будь ласка, якщо ми будемо займатися
підводним плаванням,
нам потрібен гідрокостюм, погодьтеся, добре зроблено, нам
також потрібні ласти, нам потрібна трубка
і трубка  окуляри, тому ще раз, коли ми займаємося
підводним плаванням,
нам потрібні окуляри, що має трубка,
а які ще ласти, добре зроблені,
тепер давайте обговоримо кікбоксинг, що нам
потрібно для кікбоксингу, коли ми займаємося
кікбоксингом,
нам потрібні боксерські рукавички, нам потрібні кросівки,
і нам також потрібна боксерська сумка, але  у нас його немає
, давайте швидко запишемо
слова, які починаються на букву B, удари назад,
добре зроблено, що нам потрібно для
сноуборду, коли ми катаємося на сноуборді, нам
потрібен шолом сноуборд та окуляри для
захисту від снігу та вітру для йоги що
робити  нам потрібен для йоги для йоги нам потрібен
килимок і розслабся
те, що ми не обговорювали це хокей то
що нам потрібно для хокею
нам потрібен шолом нам потрібна шайба і
ключка але у нас немає ковзанів давайте
напишемо  це вниз ковзани
Браво ідеально, так що швидко нагадає мені,
що це за йога, це підводне плавання, а
це зараз на борту цей
кікбоксинг, що залишилося хокей
Браво, хлопці, ваше домашнє завдання на наступний
урок я хочу, щоб ви написали речення,
які види спорту вам подобаються чи не  не подобається
використовувати приклад подивіться Мені подобається
йога, тому що вона розслабляє, або я не
люблю йогу, тому що вона нудна, ви
також можете сказати, що я люблю кікбоксинг, тому що це
захоплююче, або я не люблю кататися на сноуборді,
тому що це небезпечно, добре зроблено я
чую  дзвіночок це означає, що нам
потрібно зупинити урок, побачимось наступного разу
дуже дякую до побачення
[Музика]
ти